hi this is Dr Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason I O
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught Philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
I come in
to help students and lifelong Learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to YouTube many
viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos each
of them focused on One Core concept from
an important philosophical text I hope
you find it useful as well
in his treaties on the anger of God
there are two ancient philosophical
schools that will come in for
considerable analysis and criticism by
lactances one of them is the epicureans
who he treats first and then he'll
discuss the stoics and he seems to think
that the stoics are less wrong than the
epicureans but they still manage to get
some things Incorrect and so they also
will have a mistaken viewpoint on
whether or not it makes sense to
attribute anger to God and so he's going
to say they're they're only partly wrong
why well because they as he says
entertain better sentiments who say
there is kindness in God but not anger
and then he says a very pleasing and
popular speech that God is Not subject
to such littleness of Mind as to imagine
he is injured by anyone since it is
impossible for him to be injured and in
in some respect lactancius is also
targeting fellow Christian thinkers who
would say oh no no no you know God is
just loving and good and beneficent God
never gets angry that that stuff talked
about in in you know the writings Ah
that's just anthropomorphizing don't
worry about that sort of thing like
tancius is saying no no God actually
does get angry and exhibit kindness and
in fact in chapter uh six he's going to
say God is angry precisely because of
his kindness but how do we get there
well so the stoics
think that anger is as he says a
commotion commotion right and
perturbation
perturbazzio a stirring up of the mind
and that this would be inconsistent with
God right it would be Unbecoming of the
Divine like he says when it falls on the
mind of any person as a violent Tempest
it excites such waves that it changes
the condition of the mind and then we
get a very interesting description this
is kind of a common place in ancient
philosophical discussions of anger we
see this for example in senecas on anger
and plutarchs you know on controlling
anger so you know this isn't really
becoming of the highest being in the
universe and he's going to make an ah
fortiori argument here that the stoics
would advance
namely that if anger is Unbecoming to a
human being provide provided they be of
a wisdom and Authority how much so is so
foul a change Unbecoming to God and if a
human being when they have authority and
power inflicts widespread injury through
anger sheds blood overthrows cities
destroys communities reduces provinces
to Desolation how much more is it to
believe be believed that God since he
has power over the whole human race and
the universe itself would have been
about to destroy all things if he was
angry so the idea is God doesn't get
angry I mean look at the world exists
human beings when they're angry they're
very destructive God's not going to do
that sort of thing
and
lactancias is going to say okay fair
enough but use stoics you're missing out
on something you're stressing the good
side he says they think so great and
permission pernicious and evil ought to
be absent from God and if anger and
excitement are absent from him uh well
then what remains being calm propitious
beneficent the preserver isn't that nice
right this is what the divine nature
involves and then he says well
no that's not quite capturing what God
is why because if God is not angry with
the MP MPS and the unrighteous it's
clear he does not love the pious and the
righteous therefore the error of those
is more consistent who take away anger
and kindness in opposite matters it's
necessary to be moved to both sides or
to neither he goes on he who loves the
good also hates the wicked that's part
of what it means to love in the first
place if you love this you hate the
opposite the loving of the good arises
from the hatred of the wicked and the
hatred of the wicked has its rise from
the love of the good there's no one who
loves life without hatred of death he
says or who is desirous of light but
avoids but he who avoids Darkness these
are so connected by Nature the one
cannot exist with the other the other so
he's saying here that you're not seeing
the connection Between Love and Hate and
therefore between kindness and anger you
can't have the two of these in a
rational wise being without having the
other one and this is where you stoics
are going wrong and he's got a very
interesting analogy here which he'll use
at several points about the owner or
master of a household and he says in
this case if a master has in his
household a good and a bad servant it's
evident he doesn't hate them both or
confer upon both benefits and honors if
he does this he's unjust and foolish
right so you know use stoics you want to
say that God would have the virtues of
wisdom and justice
but if you construe God as being like
this you know
master of a household or owner of a
business pick whatever you want who
doesn't actually take cognizance of
whether people are doing the right thing
or the wrong thing and thereby be moved
by emotions toward you know good ones
towards the one person the good person
and bad ones or you know hostile ones
towards the uh bad person well then your
God isn't much of a god he's not just
he's not wise so eustoics you've screwed
up here he also brings up another point
where he's going to say the stoics
partly right partly wrong and this is in
Chapter 13 where he's talking about
Providence now Providence is this notion
that there is a you know sort of plan a
structure a ruling he uses the word
Administration Administration or
governing gubernacio quite often in this
treaties and so you know he thinks that
God is a Hands-On kind of God and he
thinks that the stoics you know are
right in saying that God is like that as
well and that the world was actually
made for us on our account for human
beings right and this is indeed a
traditional stoic teaching that uh
irrational nature exists for the sake of
rational nature which includes us and
also God and you know any other rational
beings right
so he thinks of stocks are right about
that but then he brings up a challenge
that the academics have a very
understandable challenge hey if that's
the case then why is this universe
filled with so many things that are
opposed to us and going Beyond being
opposed that are hostile to us and going
Beyond being hostile that actually hurt
us that are damaging to us I mean think
about it there's so many ways that you
can get injured or killed in this world
including by other human beings but all
the different creatures you know there
are diseases
uh various other things natural
disasters that just you know happen to
us you know like an earthquake or
volcano or you know if we're thinking
about uh shows from the 1970s quicksand
which doesn't seem to be as prevalent as
those shows made it out to be but you
know the the academics are saying hey
why isn't Universe set up in such a way
that we don't run into all these evils
and he says that the stoic response to
this is actually quite foolish what is
the stoic response well you just haven't
seen the big picture yet all of these
things are actually useful or helpful to
us human beings in one way or another
they're not really bads they're not
really evils and he's got you know kind
of a throwaway line here which is which
is quite funny he brings up
um
animals you know like uh the Viper when
burnt and reduced to ashes is a remedy
for the bite of the same beast and we
might say the same thing about like uh
you know milking snakes Venom to make
anti-venom right or toxins or whatever
whatever it happens to be
um and then he says wouldn't it have
been a lot simpler just not to make a
snake in the first place or don't give
them Venom right how much better had it
been that it should not exist at all
then that a remedy should be required
against it drawn from itself he doesn't
interestingly say you stoics you don't
actually know whether any of these
things are good for us or not he just
says let's assume they are
doesn't it seem like a very roundabout
way for God to do things so that's kind
of an interesting argument and then the
third thing the third criticism is
really that the stoics made a
fundamental error in their approach to
the emotions and the error consists in
this
not seeing that there is good and bad or
just an unjust anger and he discusses
this in chapter 17 where he's going to
tell us that to be angry is actually on
the part of reason if it's just anger
right The Faults are removed
licentiousness is curbed this is plainly
in accordance with Justice and wisdom so
it makes sense for human beings
sometimes to get angry and for God to
get angry as well but the stoics failing
to make the distinction between just and
unjust anger they thought that it was
all unjust or bad and he says because
they didn't find a remedy for the matter
uh medal amre right they wanted to
excise anger entirely and if you look at
you know for example seneca's uh work on
anger I think this kind of exemplifies
it you know he tries to close off any
possibility of anger being good or
helpful or useful or necessary in any
way
and then he says
um the philosophers were ignorant of
what's translated here is the nature of
anger but we could say the account of
anger
what anger you know uh would would be
what what it's
um reason what its structure what the
account of it would be and because the
philosophers were ignorant of this their
definitions aren't very good well
they're they're good for a certain kind
of anger right as he goes on and he says
this is the unjust anger concerning
which we spoke before which is Con
contained even in Dumb animals to be
restrained in human beings lest they
rush to some very great evil through
rage so those definitions are okay for
unjust wrong
vicious anger right and what are these
definitions he says you know
um Seneca tells us in his book on anger
anger is the desire of avenging an
injury or the desire of punishing the
person by whom you think you've been
unfairly injured an incitement of the
mind to injure him who has either
committed an injury or his wish to do so
he also brings up Aristotle but we don't
we're not looking at the criticism here
so we don't have to worry about that
right and he goes on to say well you
know there is the possibility of just
anger God exhibits just anger as do some
human beings and so they should have
given this definition
anger is an emotion of the Mind arousing
itself for the restraining
of faults if anger is understood in that
way well then anger is actually
something not only good but something
just something needed something required
and so God could in fact feel and should
feel and does feel according to lock
tons yes that kind of anger the stoics
just didn't see that and that's why they
remove Anger from God so we've got some
interesting criticisms of the stoic
approach to anger as well as to you know
the world and Providence made by
lotancias here in his treaties on the
anger of God are they entirely on point
could the stoics possibly respond to
them maybe but these are you know what
we find here in the text